but we continue to search
[Music]
life
looks for life
I am super excited today am I excited to
butcher the pronunciation of Chinese
names not really but we did get the
first teaser trailer for the Netflix
adaptation of one of my favorite book
series remembrance of Earth's past by
sisine Liu which is better known and
often referred to as the name of the
first book of the series The Three body
problem the TV show drops the the from
the title and three body problem is set
to arrive on Netflix in January of 2024
and I'm just gonna say it right up front
that this teaser looks amazing and
through watching and re-watching it I
realized that most of what jumps out at
me is pretty firmly in spoilers
territory for people who haven't read
the books so what I'm going to do today
in this video is go through some of the
background and set up for what to expect
in the first season based on what we see
here without spoiling any of the big
story points the official synopsis from
Netflix reads the series will follow
what happens when a young woman's
fateful decision in 1960s China
reverberates across space and time to a
group of brilliant scientists in the
present day as the laws of nature
unravel Before Their Eyes five former
colleagues reunite to confront the
greatest threat in Humanity's history
there are several shots in the trailer
that feature the young woman from China
from that description and so I guess I
should mention that these books were
first published in China the author
cecin Liu wrote them in Chinese and then
they were translated around the world
the translated versions begin with the
story of yahwehie and that starts during
the cultural revolution which is a
somewhat complicated period of history
that I'm not really interested in going
into in this video but we do see this
character at a struggle session this is
early in her life and what's imp
important is the effect it has on her
later and how it influences that fateful
decision that they mentioned in the
synopsis from there you see this large
radio telescope on top of a mountain
this is called red Coast base in the
book and you can see that yeah works
there this is a radio telescope in a
remote location and these shots are
really promising they look great which
indicates that the show is operating
with a healthy budget and also I can
instantly recognize what's happening in
them the shots shown here are important
and it looks like they did a more than
competent job of bringing them to life
this is what got me excited initially
because of three body problem Works
it'll be bringing two of my favorite
things in the whole world together an
epic sci-fi series that spans a vast
amount of time and a high quality
multi-season TV show what I loved about
these books were the concepts they
explore and the questions they ask you
to consider what I love about TV V is
that it's a visual medium and when it's
done right it can do a great job of
exploring character so when I think of a
good adaptation I'm not looking for a
chapter by chapter retelling I'm looking
for something that brings those Concepts
to Life by using the tools the visual
medium has at its disposal that said
everything here is fairly recognizable
there are no major surprises and some
things look exactly how they were
described on the page the casting is a
little bit odd because the first book
does primarily take place in China with
Chinese characters which doesn't seem to
be the case in the show that's not to
say that the books don't become more
International as they continue but that
doesn't happen until the second and
third volumes to take that back to the
description though it says that the
Fateful decision reverberates across
space and time to a group of brilliant
scientists in the present day we know
from the casting announcement that these
will be played by Jess Hong Alex sharp
Joven adefo Aiza Gonzalez and John
Bradley so those are not a bunch of
Chinese people that's pretty obvious and
this is a diversion from The Source
material but it's not that hard to
imagine scientists from outside of China
being involved with some of what happens
in the first book in fact there are a
lot of scenes in this trailer that don't
look like they even take place on Earth
let alone China and that's because the
title three body refers to a virtual
reality game this is where most of the
Fantastical shots in the trailer come
from and it looks like we see some of
those scientists playing the game
there's one good shot of the headset and
then other shots where you see temples
pyramids armies flying through the air
and some of those scientists wearing
robes which I would guess is all inside
the BR environment one of the names I
was surprised to see on the character
announcements was so fun which is a
character that doesn't get involved with
the story until later she's played by C
shamooka and I noticed the katana
strapped to her back right away and I
guess her being in the game would work
the game has a sort of narrator that
it's just a voice as far as I can
remember so adding a body would be a
visual upgrade and that will also set up
some interesting stuff for later on in
the story I guess the character swaps
are what they are they could add some
depth overall and it is kind of nice to
see Game of Thrones alumni John Bradley
there hasn't been much promo material
circulated around but the few shots of
them filming that are out there look
intriguing enough they bring to mind
that last line in the description as the
laws of nature unravel Before Their Eyes
five former colleagues reunite to
confront the greatest threat in
Humanity's history and I'll tell you
that threat in the way people react to
it is what drives the series I mentioned
being in love with the concepts earlier
and the teaser does a great job of
sparking interest in those through a
voiceover from Carl Sagan he says as
children we fear the dark anything might
be out there the unknown troubles us
there are those who say we should not
inquire too closely into who else might
be living in that Darkness better not to
know but we continue to search life
looks for life I believe this originally
came from his TV series Cosmos but when
I look the quote up I found this series
of tribute videos called Sagan Series
this is from the second one that's
titled life looks for life and I'll put
a link to that in the description life
looking for life is an interesting
starting point red Coast bass and the
radio telescope there might give you a
hint about how things develop what's
great about this quote which is edited
down to fit into the teaser is that it
points out two opposing views in
relation to the search for
extraterrestrial life perhaps the more
logical approach that we shouldn't
inquire too closely and then the one
that's more in line with our human
nature which is of course life looks for
life one other thing I have to mention
is that there are a couple of scenes in
this teaser that aren't from the first
book which I think is likely because the
story isn't completely told in
chronological order as new characters
are introduced we learn where they were
in relation to other events and
considering the show has complete
information to work with I don't see a
problem with introducing some of these
characters earlier when those things are
happening so that viewers will already
be familiar with them rather than using
flashbacks when they show up later so
besides that I don't see anything in the
trailer to say that they're covering
more than the first book I don't think
they're trying to cram all of it into
the first season or whatever we do know
that there are eight episodes but we
don't know the episode lengths so I
think for the most part season one will
in the same place that the first book
does chronologically so again I'm super
excited with how this looks and think
there's real potential for this to be a
great adaptation you probably noticed
the text that says from the creators of
Game of Thrones that is referring to
David Benny often D.B Weiss who were the
showrunners of that show and who are the
show Runners here and they've joined
forces with Alexander Wu as co-creators
I imagine this will bring up some Sour
feelings for some fans but let me remind
you that Seasons three and four of Game
of Thrones were some of the best TV ever
produced period regardless of how you
feel about how the series ended these
guys have proven that they can manage an
adaptation of something that was
considered to be unfilmable and that may
come in handy as three body progresses
this is just the beginning of the story
and the scope and scale get insane from
here I think it's worth saying that
there are some real challenges ahead but
the reward could well be worth the risk
if they can pull it off plus the story
is complete remembrance of Earth's past
has a beginning middle and definitive
end if they can get there which is
always a big if whenever it shows on
Netflix I understand that kind of
anxiety you might have if they can get
there this really does have a chance at
being one of the best Sci-Fi TV series
of all time before I wrap it up I would
highly recommend that you read these
books if you like those which I think
you will and you like the idea of a
straightforward almost one for one
adaptation than 10 cent out of China has
a 30 episode first season of a TV show
that covers the first book I wouldn't
suggest that as a starting point if
you're coming from the West there'll be
a little bit of a disparity in
production value and as mentioned it is
a straight adaptation so they didn't
really try to make it into a great TV
show they tried to Faithfully put
everything that happened in the book on
the screen which is a different kind of
thing not bad necessarily but the books
are a better introduction and personally
I would prefer to listen to the audio
books which are pretty good rather than
watch that 30 episode series again you
can find that on YouTube if you're
interested though this teaser has so
many shots I can't wait to see there's
this one with the number scrawled on the
wall that is related to the thing that
hooked me into the series initially when
I read it you might recognize Benedict
Wong here he's playing one of my
favorite characters dashu and there are
a couple of other Game of Thrones
connections Jonathan price and Liam
Cunningham will both appear Cunningham
is particularly funny to me because the
character he plays is very on Davos if
that makes sense and there's just so
much I can't really talk about without
spoilers so I'll just say that if you
like big sci-fi Concepts you're in for a
treat and I think that is a great place
to leave things I'll be covering this
show as much as there is to cover I've
been thinking about making videos about
the book series for years so I'll
probably go ahead and do that and I'm
interested to see what you think so let
me know in the comments please like this
video If you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
foreign